so this is really interesting and I've
been wanting to talk about GMOs and as
you guys know I say this on the show
often I am NOT a scientist and I do
sometimes muck up some the science stuff
so I wanna clean up some GMO stuff and I
just watched Food Inc so I'm on a big
kick with all this stuff so natural food
blogs are freaking out uh because there
is some news that cows may soon be
forced to feed on GMO or genetically
modified grass uh so first off let's
just get the definition of what a GMO is
now had actually a little trouble
finding a clear definition of this
because it's so polarizing that every
bit of information you get on it others
people are completely against it or
people that are completely for it so the
information that we're going and we can
throw to it now what are GMOs and this
is from the non-gmo project okay
unbiased reporting so I I think this is
basically going to be somewhat um bison
is an idea Bubba Cara to clean up after
so GMOs or genetically modified
organisms are plants or animals that
have been genetically engineered with
DNA from bacteria viruses or other
plants and animals these experimental
combinations of genes from different
species cannot occur in nature or in
traditional crossbreeding so virtually
all commercial GMOs are engineered to
withstand direct application of
herbicide and or to produce an
insecticide despite biotech industry
promises none of the GMO traits
currently on the market offer increased
yield drought tolerance enhanced
nutrition or any other consumer benefit
uh and a growing body of evidence
connects GMOs with help health problems
environmental damage and violation of
farmers and consumers rights okay so now
Cara I know you're pro GMO so by
thinking of an issue with that last part
at least
but basically was the definition did we
get a clear definition of what GMOs are
and this has been going on forever where
farmers try to make better crops right
not not I mean we're probably talking
about agriculture scientists at this
point not like backyard farmers but no
like so much of that was wrong and
really biased and not based on okay that
was from the non-gmo
graduation why it's obviously very bite
and that's why I want to do this because
I know your feelings on this are why I
threw that out there yes that's half of
it give me the other first things first
let's differentiate between genetically
modified and transgenic I do think that
most people now when they use the term
GMO they are talking about transgenic
organisms genetic modification just
means that you're manipulating the
genome of an organism there's lots of
ways to do it you can do it through
breeding through different types of
domestication but yes I think that we
just quickly spend why the reason that
farmers do that is because they want
things that will last longer right
everybody like from the beginning of
Agriculture we've been breeding like oh
that tomato's bigger that tomato's
bigger let's cross them we want the
bigger tomato like that's technically
that is genetic modification everything
we eat right now has been genetically
modified but I'll concede that what
we're probably talking about when we use
the label GMO is transgenics which means
manipulating the genome with specific
chemicals and altering it in such a way
to get a specific result now advocates
of GMO research which is almost all
scientists yeah they will tell you that
it's better to manipulate a single gene
to get a single outcome than not better
but it's it's more controlled then when
we use kind of standard practice which
is just a crossbreeding you're shuffling
around thousands of genes the concern
that a lot of people have is this would
never occur in nature yeah this would
never well first of all that's a really
difficult claim to make there are a lot
of things in this situation that could
occur in nature there are some things
that couldn't occur in nature but I have
a huge problem with people that argue
that because something is non natural it
somehow unhealthy or dangerous right so
to that point we also do story coupling
to know how when you buy things the
packaging on all your food and all that
stuff when they say all-natural it
actually literally means nothing in the
United States you're free means nothing
all natural it is natural to brush your
teeth it's unnatural to fix a cleft
palate right it's you know all of these
things are unnatural but that does not
mean that they are somehow better or
worse that's just an absolutely moot
point it's a it's a straw man argument
okay so we got the non GMO people we got
the Cara Santa Maria people there's a
lot better yes
yeah what we're gonna question you seem
to be very well-informed like how much
do we know about the potential
consequences of jameth do we know that
they are safe in other words that's the
argument that I see most of the time
it's like well we just don't have enough
information but do we have enough
information convey it depends on where
your threshold is I'm going to be
completely honest it depends on where
your threshold is but that last you know
paragraph that you read off of there
about there's evidence to show that they
are increasingly danger but while that's
[ __ ]
like it's straight-up propaganda that's
not based in any legitimate sign so
there's no chance that that somehow
superbugs are coming because they're
getting because the plants are more
resistant from antibiotic resistance
yeah that's a whole different issue yeah
so here's the thing there has not been
one repeatable legitimate study that
shows any risk to health or human safety
not one yeah
not one so when people claim that
they're straight up they're perpetuating
a myth and that's a very important point
hands down to make